more fallout after the release of the
Inspector General Spicer Report Attorney
General William Barr blasting the AG's
conclusions bar calling out the FBI and
also going after the media I felt this
was very flimsy these omissions were not
satisfactorily explained and I think
that leaves open the possibility to
infer a bad faith I think our nation was
turned on its head for three years I
think based on a completely bogus
narrative that was largely flam fanned
and hyped by an irresponsible press and
I think that there were gross abuses of
FISA an inexplicable behavior that it is
intolerable in the FBI the Attorney
General also doubling down on his
assertion that the Trump campaign was
spied on
it was clearly spied upon I mean that's
what electronic surveillance is I think
wiring people up to go in and talk to
people and make recordings of their
conversations is spying Jesse you have
been deep in the state of mind on this
report and you read I watch you you want
you read the whole executive summary
yesterday you were underlining things
I'm not an expectorant what specifically
to ask you about but maybe we just
talked about Bill bar as the Attorney
General it's saying basically this he's
saying that the Inspector General did
not hit the mark what he's saying is
that when you open up an investigation
into an opposing political campaign and
if you're the FBI and you open it up
based on foreign rumors that is a very
thin predicate to base that on and not
only Jews open up an investigation on to
one 28 year old who has a drunken
conversation at a bar you all of a
sudden open on Flynn open on manna fort
and open on page that is dramatic to do
at that point all he's saying is why
didn't the FBI give a defensive briefing
to the Trump campaign people say oh well
you don't want to tip the Trump campaign
off well you went to the Russians you
alerted the Russians that summer hey
stop messing around we know what you're
doing but you don't go to
the Trump campaign you don't think they
could have gone to Jeff Sessions and say
hey there's going to be some
infiltration opportunity better watch
out there could be some issues let me
show you how to deal with it no they
investigated the Trump campaign and not
the Russians okay second point the
spying occurred there was wiretapping
and there was undercover agents that
went in and secretly recorded Trump
campaign officials the dossier according
to the Inspector General was the central
and essential document used to wiretap
the campaign the FBI lawyer said this
was essentially a single source FISA and
they drew almost entirely from the steel
dossier that means Hillary bought a
warrant that means Hillary paid for
foreign interference in an election and
they knew almost immediately the dossier
was bogus because when they interviewed
the source of Steele's ridiculous report
he said oh yeah it's all it's all
nothing it's all hearsay it's all junk
steel doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about
and they continued for a year to lie
about steel and to deceive the court and
to forge documents to make it look like
Paige was a bad guy when in fact he was
a good guy and that was the most
egregious thing because you can look at
the end of this Muller what does he do
for two years he knows there's no
collusion they knew for years there was
no collusion yet they put the country
through hell to build an obstruction
case this was not an unbiased
investigation I don't care what they say
they had no evidence of ice that's just
because they didn't even admit it of
course they're not dumb enough to me
whine about this so that one of the
things that in the report the IG said is
that there that the Warrens were
justified that there was evidence for it
and that they couldn't say what the
other evidence is and that that
apparently is because it must come from
another source like the CIA perhaps
correct and I think the IG report Dana
speaks for itself and this is not you
know bill Barse great at spin apparently
I think better at spin than it being
Attorney General and what he did with
the Muller report was he was able to
preempt it and
to try to define it before it was out in
public with this case you know you
couldn't do it bill bar because guess
what
bill bar you have robert muller working
for you you've got John Durham whose
report you're now going to control
working for you but you don't have
Michael Horowitz the Inspector General
working for you he's independent so his
analysis comes out and as I said the
report is very clear there was no
political bias zero okay so then why'd
they lie and deceive the court they
didn't deceive the they didn't for me
documents they did not there was
information and there was one person who
made and this is you know now famous
seventeen clerical errors or whatever
wasn't one pretty lied but you know what
wouldn't be referred to what here is it
doesn't even matter what's in the report
even though we can all read it because
the right wing will continue with
conspiracy theories that can't was clean
and you were wrong had nothing to do
with the fire and you were wrong you
were wrong the whole time it was that in
fact that's unbelievable that you would
say anybody except you know what you
should say well I apologize because this
report is out now that they've got this
report they they're gonna do an audit
they might have some changes but there's
like no consequences and also you
haven't heard any but I think the media
doesn't really say that the Obama
administration that somebody had to have
been checking this stuff up and they and
when they knew that the dossier was a
fraud they didn't want to tell anybody
because they realized they were that's
the gooey hot center to all of this it
really bothers me because it puts
barroom stories like I have a million
barroom stories this entire what Jesse
said is true this was based on a on
barroom gossip that even steel couldn't
verify and said he couldn't back up and
yet that was the thing that launched a
three-year witch trial a bar my god I
have bar wounds stories that could this
is that
but you wouldn't want you say
conspiracies that's the best that's the
conspiracy theory to kill all conspiracy
theories a golden shower tape that never
happened that would had to do in Obama's
bed that he stayed in a hotel and a
trump walked in there decided to hey
let's defile this bed that's a
conspiracy and the thing is also about
the 17 mistakes they are all mistakes
but they're all mistakes in one
direction and if it's in the same
direction benefit in one perspective I
think you called maybe that's why the
FBI agents were cheering on the FBI is
going to surveil page but pages also and
it says in the report a source for the
CIA so how does that work well that's
why we're missing a lot of evidence that
Durham has referenced and I think the
important part here is to respond to
your point you know the attorneys for
the OIG they take as testimony true they
take as testimony fact meaning if
someone says nope I am NOT biased then
they will put that down and say okay
then there was no bias and I think the
most important part the crucial element
to this is the fact that the Attorney
General has come out and said that there
are gross and clear abuse of their
surveillance process and what we see
here in these mistakes which I refuse to
call them that they are clear omissions
as you said it was always to one side
this includes these conceptually
monitored statements from both page and
Manta forth but that was exculpatory if
that if one of us was being prosecuted
and you learned that prosecution with
held consistently exculpatory evidence
and then the Attorney General and says
comes out and says during the
investigation it was consistently excope
everything we uncovered was to one side
where do we stop where does the
investigation stop why then did they
keep going until they found a modicum a
tiny bit of evidence that went to the
truth that they had already concluded
the answer is this impeach